hello I'm Greg I'm John John have you
heard of this movie called atomic blonde
I think we should watch like the 16
second teaser we watched the trailer for
the trailer just not one day ago I found
out in that time that the uncredited
director of the first John wick there
are two directors and yeah you know DJ
gets weird about [ __ ] like that
yeah only one of them got chance the
house key but he was you know it was
pretty much known that this other guy
co-directed a film okay maybe he maybe
he didn't do that with John way to me
that suppose might have been missing for
us David Lynch leash is the guy yeah
anyway alright uh yeah new action film
directed this [ __ ] okay I could prove I
could still do it guys screwed she still
so sexy
[Music]
see this is the lighting I was missing
for the first job like here right here
oh my god oh hell yeah
I'm already loving this Oh female WIC
yeah Shane Twix J WIC I don't think
crossing over I've heard it and so cool
oh damn Charlize Theron is really
throwing down sound effects are a little
off okay
oh I already have several reasons why
I'm sad for this dry text Lorraine Bruce
makes for an escape-and-evasion
diligence collection let's have a crack
shall we go away and now time to combat
a set of skills talents can be overlaid
Lorraine how will you know James
Gascoigne enough to say though he's dead
yeah we're fine down honey down our
operatives what a lot of brave men and
women you're gonna show up that stated
possible is that Mac welcome to my man
[ __ ] sake
trust no one
oh you look like you need saving
oh this movie
so you made contact with the French
operative obviously
[Music]
nice I think I [ __ ] love you oh boy
boy howdy I thought I was know so
[ __ ] cool so cool
it's like female John wick and female
James Bond all at the same time that
looks awesome
yeah you could definitely see the John
wick style a direction there yeah in
terms of the way the lighting is in the
framing of things and the way the action
scene itself was playing out Leah if you
take the grit of like Casino Royale or
you know the board yeah I'm gonna see
and then crash that into like this 80s
nostalgia yeah going through it kinda
reminds me of like haywire it's a bit of
like Kingsman would slow down
yeah it's things are really awesome
first off Charlize Theron like the
second as it was going now does you're
just getting ready and it's reminding me
of like like La Femme Nikita like the
okay the good old Oh Luke Bissel Luke
bass song like Luke like it's like a
lute bass on film where you got this
like hot ass female action lead but done
in a way that's more I feel more toned
down and sense of I can feel there's
still of somewhat of a reality to this
world we're supposed to like fifth
element or Lucy you know these are no
Femme Nikita was like that was just a
dangerous lethal woman yeah yeah one
that seems to be the what they're trying
to steep us in here it's very much like
they're all doing this right now and
it's still pretty felt like you know
we're really putting our effort into
making this all feel like it's real so
and as much as we're gonna go home so
it's just a female John wick I was like
yeah yeah well John wick hell yeah
because like honestly I thought not then
I think that's a cool way to do it
almost like if you I don't know if this
has anything to do with the John wick
universe I kind of hope it does cuz they
don't even need to touch it's just like
oh cool a different side of
that same colorful intriguing crimes on
the same earth doesn't seem like it's
only crime seems like she kind of does
it for some good like the business of
murderers and [ __ ] like that
undercover mi6 agent that looks really
yeah it's like a female Twix meets
balling you're right you said it
perfectly yeah yeah I'm some sob super
excited that action scene what I liked
about it was it was more realistic and
they let the shots go so they weren't
trying to be like super fancy about it
some people might go it's just John wick
but keep in mind jump you never you
don't ever really see John wick use
hand-to-hand most you do sometimes but
most of the time it's its gunplay okay
here was like the hand-to-hand combat
and they were toning down and make more
real but still choreographed so well and
they could do it in one shot like people
are getting hate it looks like they're
getting hit the sound effects were
seemed a little off oh yeah that sound
of Exile look it's not quite matching
for me that could just be the byproduct
of an internet trailer like I hope
that's not how it how that so they'll
enhance the punch noise yeah and
trailers yeah I like that
Charlize Theron is having this sort of
crest into you know like she's getting
to have like a badass phase of her yeah
you know like she's gonna do it was her
Lisa did her like any number of guys
she's on with Scarlett Johansson's doing
right now yes Scarlett Johansson you
know you got Mad Max then you got you
know she'd do it her big wacky
blockbuster with fast and furious no
she's doing this yeah she looks like a
[ __ ] no I'm sure she goes this is like
the ultimate female assassin movie the
action looks great you got hot female
lead we have a lesbian scene in here
she's gay I'm curious great about how
this movie's gonna play out but yet how
sexy did that sexy look this pretty set
this is pretty sex yet no tell me yeah
how old is Charlize Theron's 1975 so
she's like 47:36
was great she was amazing well done man
I hope to look that good when I'm her
age and owe the other thing to James
Macari gosh you generate a scenario John
given in there
got Toby Jones Toby Jones yeah Jones
James McAvoy remember a couple weeks ago
I was saying I feel like James McAvoy
could be Caitlyn could have like his own
action sort of franchise and I was
pointing to like wanted and how amazing
it was you see what I said the amazing I
wanted it's awesome gunplay yeah yeah
that movie was really cool he's really
cool in it it's all character artists
he's a badass character I'm so bummed
we've doesn't seem like we're ever gonna
get it wanted to yeah but then you throw
them into like this universe granted you
don't see any like gun action scenes are
here would here with him but I feel like
we're gonna get some action with James
McAvoy that they're leaving out of the
trailer right now the problem he looks
like he can do time jack but I know he's
in the excellent movies but he's just
Professor X ain't like throwing down his
fist and [ __ ] or shooting anything so I
feel like James McAvoy
I feel like he would could have a really
cool action like movie for sure oh yeah
now I like wanted was great but now that
we know who he is yet have a great one
but I feel like he would be more suited
into like a crime world oh yes like I
feel ready one yeah you know more on the
Guy Ritchie into the scale yeah and you
know the big done like good luck but she
just bored or something yeah I'm really
excited for this I hope this is really
good yeah yeah this is this is high up
on my list like I'm gonna be there with
popcorn man cuz maybe he wasn't
co-directing part two of John wick and
he was working on this cuz they're
coming out like close enough to each
other
yes what year you know and it makes me
it does make me curious you know and
this is our sampling budget yeah I
understand that they they co-directed
the first one together then the second
one did did the one guy just err is it
just chest hausky to director that part
- yeah I think so okay like it I guess I
can see it I get what their each of
their half is kind of like now yeah I
feel like because John wick is less you
know crazy with its you know visual look
then so the first one is and this has
all that stuff in it so yeah is that
credit for John wick to and director I
think it's cool when you have a team and
then you see what they do separately oh
yeah just to see what their different
flavors are you know I was excited about
John wick too and I liked John wick -
you don't even despite a couple rezerve
I'm really excited for this also I'm
glad these dudes are making action this
looks this looks [ __ ] awesome
like you said like the old Guy Ritchie
like lock stock yeah like that Guy
Ritchie mixed with you know BA a bond
and Ja wig together like it's so cool
it's like a different part of the
criminal underworld yeah and it's also
God that's British hoping we're
discriminatory yeah yeah it's got that
kind of scuzzy I'm I'm on it too you
know
well yeah but you know jumping she's
undercover yeah in crime I really think
they could cross yeah tell me I mean
according to this IMDB it says something
that it's like based off some type of
graphic novel I think they can make
board is watching the trailer I was like
this is one of the few crossovers I'm
actually wishing for right the wick is
kind of like a cool graphic novel Oh
totally and it's very picturesque like
some of those pic like there it seems
like there gonna be a lot of picturesque
frames yeah every kind of sequence they
showed us whether it was an action
sequence or just like heard a hotel
talking blah blah blah everything looked
like it had some very striking yeah like
solid visual directions hell yeah that
stuff's excited atomic blonde you know
who is the first person to mention this
to me that this was out who tell me I
want to know
joven flex flex for joven flex joven
flex Jonah Hex this flex is for you oh
man I'm flexing too but I have a sweater
on and not much more than up cold now
someone's gonna text you lip rope Greg
lifts like three to six times a week so
wide range in the seven-day period
subscribe to the real rejects oh yeah I
got a little nuff playing that Val
everyone's saying I click that valve
ringing dings look look that battle
again notify hang on the notification
bell John's reasons check Twitter
Instagram and he's the social media
manager of the real rejects emblem house
good day to you Charlize Theron Oh
my god